[Music]
house majority whip
jim clyburn is blaming some democratic
election losses on defunding the police
movement
we keep making that mistake this
foolishness
about you've got to be this progressive
of that progressive
that phrase the funded police
costs jamie harrison tremendously
slogan aaron kills people
slogan air destroys movements stop
slogan area
well how about stop doing it here to
react as the host of the reuben report
an author of don't burn this book think
for yourself in an age of
unreasoned dave rubin dave now he says
it
all you had to do was stand up to kamala
harris who was for defunding the police
out in
los angeles they took millions out as
well as a billion dollars out of the
police budget in the nypd
and millions out of minneapolis now he
speaks up
yeah this is so typical of what has
happened with the left
and the sort of internal war between the
progressives and whatever
is left of a moderate democrat and i'm
not really sure how much is left
although clyburn's sort of
taking the mantle right there i mean
look in effect nobody
nobody except the radicals that want
violence on the streets and that want
mayhem
nobody besides that wants the police to
be defunded
even in places in black communities
where crime is high they want more
policing i mean there's
there's a lot of evidence of this you
only want less policing if you want
chaos and i think
the the progressives in many cases they
do want that chaos because they
then think that that proves that somehow
the state is racist
and that then that that that in essence
is what
allows them to to run around and say
america is so terrible
look at all this but the average person
wants law and order that's that's just
very simple
and and easily understood by everybody
yeah i mean if there's modernization of
policing that could help things get
better
everybody wants to do it provide the
money for that extend time in the
academy whatever the cops say
and whatever the experts reveal by the
way in new york
front page two thousand four hundred
people uh officers have said i
quit that's a twenty five percent
increase of all of last year
where uh so it is a run for the exits
because they get no support from this
terrible
uh mayor and if they were so bad why
didn't jim clyburn say this earlier it
would have meant a lot
for the country meanwhile yesterday you
would never know it but the judiciary
chairman lindsey graham asked andy
mccabe to come in
and explain himself to what he was up to
during the the russia probe in the 2016
election
here's a little of what he gave and what
he received
if you knew then what you know now would
you have signed the warrant application
in june of 2017 against carter page no
sir
did you mislead the fisa court
uh i signed a package that included
uh numerous factual errors
general flynn's been prosecuted for
lying to the fbi
you lied to the fbi and you aren't being
prosecuted general flynn's situation in
mind
have absolutely nothing in common i
never
ever intentionally misled the fbi
you were fired from lying were you not
i was fired as the result of a deeply
unfair and flawed ig investigation
unfair and flawed which he referred to
that said that there was a reason for
the investigation
would you think i mean mccabe got
mauled yesterday what you guys didn't
show there was ted cruz
absolutely grilling him uh about the
logan act
and in essence you know this sort of
reminds me of some of the hearings we've
had on
on big tech and social media where you
know the senate brings people in they
grill them about things but what are you
going to actually
do so i'm personally i'm sort of over
the theatrics of this kind of stuff
well what are we going to actually do
are we going to actually
start arresting people are there going
to be consequences or are we going to
just do
the theater version of this because in
essence
mccabe mccabe really screwed up here and
are we just going to talk about it or
does something actually happen and dave
the other thing is
they're all not telling the truth at
different times they deny not knowing
different things so their
their stories don't intersect at all
and let's just take a look right now
about how much time the other networks
put into this
msnbc cnn abc cbs nbc zero minutes
no one covered it at all because
the russia thing just doesn't matter
anymore can you believe it
you know brian one of the things i talk
about in my book is that there's four
types of fake news a lot of people think
that fake news is just
a completely made-up story or when the
headline is different than the text of
the story but one of the types of fake
news and i think probably
the most nefarious the most dangerous
type of fake news
is when the media won't show you
something that goes against their
narrative and that is exactly what this
is
it doesn't help msnbc or cnn or even abc
or nbc it doesn't help their narrative
to talk about this story so they just
pretend that the hearings don't happen
and and thus that leaves everyone sort
of believing different things depending
on what channel you watch
and and that's a dangerous situation for
for a healthy democracy and all i can
tell you is we're not sure what's going
to happen all these legal challenges
and it looks like joe biden did get more
votes on the president as of right now
but the president got over 70 million
votes despite
all that negativity from all the other
networks and all the big tech problems
still the american people pushed it
aside and said i'm still going for that
guy
i think there's a lesson to be learned
there unless you want to ignore it
dave rubin thanks so much
thanks brian if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell